are we live
oh we're starting oh i can see the
countdown now
[Laughter]
hi everybody hi alex
much love for everybody
[Laughter]
the infinite bra is back for round two
now as eternal brah
oh man well the reason for that is
because uh
i've been kind of just resting in
silence the last uh
i don't know how many days i i've been
like experiencing life through the
peeping hole
peeping tom the keyhole of eternity like
a peeping tom
[Music]
[ __ ] great just disappearing to the
absolute
without putting the uh the costume on
because i've been expressing so much and
just you know
trying to share and stuff and
sometimes it's gonna be like you know
i'm just gonna disappear into the
absolute for a definite amount of time
in the space of no time you know
[Music]
i'm sure everyone on the path will go
through like phases where you kind of
the more you can disappear the more you
can come out
emptiness and form
yeah anyway so what's good man
yeah that's a really core point actually
on the
the journey of piercing the veils veil
and re
recognizing one's true nature is that
we pass a lot of our
time in service and we
aim to purify the
where we're coming from so that is truly
in service to these other costumes of
infinity
recognizing the true nature and in doing
so sometimes
it's important to go and recharge said
batteries
and that's the detox is and that's the
really more in-depth just abiding as
the absolute right here in rigpa just
you know this is it yeah
and yet it really still requires our
attention
on it yet as a
gym repetition to really anchor it in
better and better the in gym as a gym
bra the rest periods are almost
as important not more important than the
lifting itself
so here's the thing if you want to build
muscles how many hours a week
do you spend at the gym maybe five hours
how many times how many hours a week do
you spend resting and rebuilding the
muscle the rest of the time
so all your gains are actually made away
from the gym it's only when you let go
of the gym let go of lifting that's when
the muscles start to grow
the same with like mystical experiences
psychedelic experiences or meditative
states
it's not so much that the experience
itself matters although it's
mind-blowing
it's what you can get out of the
experience after it's over when you
start to unpack
and start to decondition yourself that's
just as important as the experience
itself but
people a lot of people get stuck in an
experience and then they never see
or what happens after the fires stop
burning and you look at your side
yes as the
incredible awakening al chemistry that
occurs
it's mission critical to take the time
to
reflect on and integrate
said mystical experiences so that we can
re-baseline
ourselves to that more elevated more
awakened
state the rest period yeah yeah yeah
oh all this uh masters like osho and
romana and uh akatoli buddha
after their awakening immediately they
retrieved into silence for many years
and uh see here's analogy that i came up
with
uh i think you'll be able to relate
so i look at the process of awakening as
lighting a piece of wood or a log or a
tree on fire
so at first the lock is just a static
solid log like a you know piece of wood
and then once you start to practice and
you start to go to this journey of
awakening you start to light the wood on
fire
and you have this glimpses of this
awakening experience where the you know
the wood catches fires for a little bit
maybe you glimpse it for like five
seconds ten seconds the first time
and then the fire sizzles out and then
you start to go deeper and deeper again
you start to decondition yourself that's
why they darken out the soul
and the spiritual highs come in you get
the spiritual high and then after the
spiritual high
oh what's left you gotta start looking
inward and clean
out what's what's left in your closet
and then
as you go on deeper and deeper into the
trip
or into the into the path the fire will
burn
more and more consistently until one day
when you have your chronicle final
awakening when you are abiding in
non-duality permanently
the fire doesn't stop burning it burns
forever but
even after the fire ceases to stop
burning
there's still going to be conditions
left in your body mind
that needs to be dissolved even after
your clinical final awakening
so after you're you know you're abiding
in rick power and natural state the fire
keeps on burning
but you still gotta it takes years for
that for the wood to completely
burn away that's why all those masters
they go into the silence
because they realize even after the fire
never ceases burning
you know there's still conditions left
from i don't know
other lifetimes or even just this
lifetime 30 35 years of conditions
and then when all the wood stops burning
the fire
is just the fire itself the sun just
burns without a single speck of like
wood or solidity inside
and all the steps in between all the
mystical experiences they're almost like
god give me like candies
the god in the cloud like drops candies
on the path for you and like you eat the
candy like holy [ __ ]
i'm closer to it i'm closer but then you
gotta move on because once you
experience something you gotta let it go
and then move on to the path deeper and
deeper
so you can't just be like eating candies
on the same spot all day long you know
what i mean
because the only way you can truly
understand something is if you let it go
same with the experiences yeah if you're
still thinking about something
then you haven't understood it it's only
when we like transcend and let go of the
self do we really understand what the
self is
for example um um
yeah this this retreat into silence is
really mission critical it
it enables the
reflective period that anchors
the abiding of
the true nature more consistently which
then
enables one to like you said
in this final stage really radiate out
like the sun effortlessly
the love light peace bliss
harmony and weave that into the fabric
in order to get to that though this
process of going in because there's so
much
outside to do to play with to experience
to
toy with and that is very in a sense
distractive and it can
intoxicate you like maya lakshmi just
just bringing you in with the fishing
reel like come over
try this try that oh you haven't tried
you never tried this one yet you haven't
tried that one yet try more try
more try more but you've already
in so many ways communed you've already
united with your true nature so take
the time to actually abide and go inward
and re-commune and re-commune and
re-abide and re-abide
until it really becomes so effortless
and then
you're right that the this ascent and
decent happen
simultaneously right right last year sri
aurobindo and the mother mural fossa
really
taught me that and you see it happening
every single day
still today today had a great
interview first interview with hula
super
incredibly perfect and then
elevating and then right afterward there
was a
process of a dark night a descent
right afterward where i was being
reflected
some sort of a still a lack belief or
impurity
or a a need to be validated or seen
this type of stuff and so immediately
afterwards so those two poles went
in the same like three hour period and
so
that's going to keep happening yeah and
then after that you reach a state of
equanimity where is that which gives
rise to both the spiritual highs
the light and the spiritual law the
darkness because in true
in true natural state there's no
distinction between lightness and
darkness
there's no distinction between self and
no self because if you ask a tree over
the cloud
hey what is consciousness what is this
no what is it it's not gonna be the [ __ ]
it's just natural natural state there's
no difference between enlightenment
not enlightenment yeah yeah
this is probably one of the most
important conversational points probably
is the the natural state aka
be here now aka rick ricka aka
void infinity aka nothingness
everythingness aka
beyond coming and going aka
buddha being and not being aka buddha
plus
atlas version you know
yeah so this the idea
of being a flower that naturally
effortlessly
blossoms to the sun is very beautiful
and very poetic
and yet there's also this
will and this choice this
very clear
am i aligned with god's love light
or am i doing something distorted for
one of my egoic layers
of identity right and so then that's
where
this quote re-alignment back
back back from the onion layer
you know arubindo and the mother called
it the first
one is inward that you go inward through
those
onion layers inward and then this ascent
and descent happens simultaneously and
then you go
outward that's the integral yoga
and that that that process of so-called
going inward has to do with that
re-aligning so when we say things like
it's a very macro level
idea is that you're already enlightened
and yet at the same time
are you attached to your egoic identity
and onion layers because if you
are then it's gonna your quote already
enlightened
is gonna show up as anger and
frustration and malevolence and not
knowing your true nature
and trying to extract from maya to get
happiness and peace etc
so i think last time we had you talk
about your steps you were three steps to
awakening you said the rehearsal was the
ego and then the ego
then there's awareness watching the ego
right and then
even the awareness gets unplugged so i
want to
delve deeper into that a little bit uh
let's let's play
for sure yeah so yeah i have the same
idea the first you're just a separate
cell of your ego
and then you start to discover oh
there's awareness there's infinite
spacious awareness around
the club at that stage
at that stage you're sort of just
finding a new solace in awareness or the
witness
you're transferring the self into this
new ground of being the spacious ground
of being
but then that's when you feel like oh
universal love
that's when you feel like there's unity
and oneness
and compassion you celebrate life love
it's like that then the next step after
that is the opposite
you go into emptiness that's the death
that's celebrating death
like what you just said two sides of the
same coin
that's when you even remove the witness
even the witness disappeared and in
stage even awareness
ceases to be something relevant
awareness and consciousness you realize
was just a solace a new kind of ground
of being that the self-heightened
but when the style really started to
drop away
you can't find consciousness or
awareness i mean sure i can say
there's consciousness right now i have
an experience but you're no longer
attached to the idea that i
am consciousness or i am awareness you
sort of disappear
into that what i call the warm blanket
of the universe
and it's just natural it's natural
that's the difference between a arahat
which is someone who is obsessed with
nirvana and death
and uh both someone who is obsessed with
love and compassion
and universal love and all that stuff
there are actually two sides of the same
coin
one celebrates life the other celebrates
death one is like hey man
i'm gonna spend the rest of my life
trying to wake people up but that's
still based on sort of a very subtle
relation uh sort of a chronic egoic
relation a little bit just a little bit
tiny tiny bit
way less than you know that you go away
state in the very first stage
but the araha he's the one that says hey
man i'm gonna go sit in my nirvana
everyone else is not woke he's still
attached to the idea of
separation just a tiny bit he wants to
enjoy his own nirvana
he thinks that nirvana is better than
everything else
buddhahood is the combination of the two
while transcending both
that's the difference between
enlightenment and buddhahood
or alignment in the natural state buddha
who just becomes a normie
he just becomes a normal person he's no
distinction at all
between death and life
nirvana and sankara non-duality and
duality all those concepts
from the buddha's perspective they all
seems empty buddha said it even the
dharma is empty
if you really understood what buddha was
saying every insight every wisdom every
mystical experience
that you accumulated throughout the path
you just threw it all away but that
doesn't mean that you can't experience
that makes you actually experience them
even deeper you can experience all the
states deeper they just become sort of
like
uh costumes like glasses you put on oh
today i'm going to put on the
non-duality glasses
yeah today i'm going to put on the
eternal glasses today i'm going to put
on the evening glasses today i'm going
to put on the awareness of awareness
glasses today i'm going to put on the
eco glasses
it's all fair say fair play it's all the
same
because awareness and consciousness is
the last lens of perception
yeah it's a lens of perception it's
clear that's why people miss it
they cleared out everything but then
they're going around saying their
awareness and consciousness but that's
still a lens of perception
once you remove that you become more
like an animal than a god or a human
it's almost like you transcend god and
human uh
yeah it just feels like you you feel
more like an animal
just supernatural natural natural state
yeah there's this like we described
we can take this from
the
this being the absolute you
being the absolute exactly where you're
at
right now and that right
totally and we can take it from there
and then we can also take it from as we
were describing where
there is this alignment with
love light and then there is the
distortion of the
ego layer out here where i'm trying to
get peace and happiness from maya
i don't know that we actually
share our awareness that we share our
source that we are the creator of this
reality when you had don't know that
data
you are so much more running algorithms
and scripts that create
suffering okay so now we have that so
that's number one like you listed is the
ego so these layers of identity
and then we become really really subtly
aware as we go inward we become
subtly aware of awareness
itself of observation itself
of witnessing and as we do that
that is also a gym repetition it's
both it's a gym repetition it's it's
both
the gradual and sudden merged into one
and so
you're you're gonna over time even today
still
there are moments where the atlas
costume is much
more aware of awareness and there are
days when it's not as aware of awareness
there are days when it's very aware of
being source of infinite possibility
it's not yeah it's all the same like
that and so okay so there's that so step
that second step is you know really kind
of becoming hyper vigilantly aware of
awareness itself
and then that's usually when people
unlock this heart chakra and they start
right
they feel that unity that love that
cosmic consciousness the christ
consciousness you begin
feeling that and you you love
service you love love love is the
vibration
of the entire planet and the whole
harmonic that's occurring
and the whole of the whole divine play
and then there's
the recognizing that even awareness
itself
just like in a dream when we simulate
out
our dreamed environment we also simulate
out the observer itself
in the dreamed environment and so like
you said it's the very last
attribute is the actual observer the
actual awareness itself is the very last
attribute to also in a sense
uh make it into an object and transcend
even the all-inclusive awareness
and then there's this emptiness
nothingness
the the very nirvana the very
and this is where it becomes two sides
of the same coin because you don't
stay there it's not a place to stay
in you take what you recognize as
all of these being dreams and dreamed
explorations
of a one infinite intelligence and you
and you decide to then be come
at merge with atlas at the same time and
and
weave your enlightened realizations into
society in terms of architecting the
frameworks
that the maximize prosperity and
abundance and play and harmony and
creativity and gifts and uniqueness
because ultimately intelligent infinity
adores the process
of expressing itself like fireworks and
that's why the frank costume looks a
certain way and this atlas costume looks
a certain way
it's because we get to express ourselves
that's why the song nwa
express yourself
don't express yourself and katy perry
baby you're a fight
that's a special song bruh
so that's also what we're talking about
the last stage is it's the last picture
of the 10 ox
xan sequence the full circle where you
kind of
you catch the object at first you see
the the first stage you see the
footprints of the ox
and you see the tail of the ox the ox
represents enlightenment for those of
you who who don't know this picture
maybe we can pull that out did we put
that last time or did
no we didn't tell me
the zen ox 10 pictures
10 steps towards uh enlightenment or
natural state
is that the 10 pictures of the the
parable
oh yeah yeah yeah i think every
tradition has its own way of talking
about those steps uh
those processes which at the end there's
no process at all there's no path at all
yeah there's the there's the ten bulls
which is yeah
and that one okay so let's let's pull it
up
right is that the temple this is the
temp
yeah in search of the discovery of the
footprints
that's when you have that's why you have
a little glimpse of it
and then perceiving the poison when you
have a glimpse of it footprints is more
like oh i read it somewhere
i read it somewhere and then finally you
perceive every give a glimpse of
the absolute infinity or the natural
state and then you go on deeper into the
path you practice even more
and then you catch the ball that's in
the ball
and then you tame the ball
that's when you really start to like
integrate with this
thing it's it's bull is such a great
metaphor because it's it's
wild it's huge i mean it is nature
itself
it's not easy to tam yeah and it's not
right
that's why all those teachers they go
into like ten seven years they say it
takes
seven to ten years to integrate this
thing which makes sense this one day
master said
it took me 12 years to get over it he's
talking about that
yeah yeah it takes 12 years to ride the
ball and tame it
wow switch from your personal identity
being this small self
inside the head this limited mitsu to
like all of reality
that's huge that's the process yeah
yeah it's we're not gonna go to the to
the gym and bench press 300 pounds day
one
yeah you're not yeah totally or the
another analogy is well after you bench
300 pounds and then you go back into the
world
how are you going to interact with
people how are you going to pick up
uh an ants with the strength of someone
who can bend 300 pound
when you're used to picking up an ants
with no strength oh it's easy but now
you have a
body of a 300 pound bench presser and
the strength of a 300 pound bench
presser how are you going to pick up an
ant and not hurt it
and then you have the number seven the
ball transcended
that's when you sort of let go of the
whole paradigm
of spirituality and awakening even out
of awakening
and then both the bull and the self are
transcended
and then you re then reach the source
and then you return to society so
basically the last picture
you just become somebody that's so
normal there's nothing spiritual about
you
you become invisible to society and then
you stop giving a [ __ ] even about trying
to share it people ask you go ahead and
tell them right yeah but
the need to teach to share the need to
even stay silent
to be in the source to be oh i mean
nirvana don't don't [ __ ] with me i'm the
mountain
that even that's gone and then there's a
lot of pictures some pictures have this
uh the last one of this is this normal
dude in the market
and he's drinking wine because his no he
sees no distinction at all between
nevada and samkara
this is no distinction of being awake
and being not awake it's all just
it's sort of like the last picture you
sort of go back to being an individual
again
instead of like perceiving everything of
course you can still perceive when
everything is god
but you you sort of the individuality
sort of return and you can express
all the previous stages through you know
just the meat suit
just the empty mitsu you become a free
authentic human being you don't really
transcend being nothing you transcend
being the godhead
you should send awareness and everything
which includes them all
that's why you say man after before
alignment is a mountain during lemon
it's not the mountain after laminate
this mountain again except
that's when the mountain really just
perceives itself
during the enlightenment he's still a
being here perceiving the crazy mountain
holy [ __ ]
mountain is like oh it's like an
astringent dmp trip but that's still
perceiving and
filtering through uh a sort of like a
separate being that's awakened
but even that has to be let go of until
there's just a mountain again
but this time the mountain is just
eternity gazing itself
infinity expressing itself because there
is a difference between infinity
expressing itself
and eternity gazing back at itself
versus
the human character perceiving infinity
the human character perceiving eternity
there
there that that that too those two
stages that during the process
that's the stage we're talking about
where you continue to
um dissolve the rest of your conditions
even after a full awakening
because it takes a while it takes a long
time to decondition yourself and one of
the really
important um blind spot one of the
really
one of the the conditions that people
tend to miss
during this process maybe the last layer
is the condition of the whole
paradigm of spirituality yes yes because
a lot of time after awakening
people continue to play the game of
spirituality
i mean oh that's fine oh that's fine oh
that's great
but they're kind of just they're peeling
away later and
they build it up again by by just you
know sort of playing
continually being stuck in the game of
spirituality spirituality
is like a mother the godfather of all
other programs
you go into spirituality to dissolve all
the previous programs like the sex
program
like the being a rich person program the
ceo program the fitness program the
science program
and then you get into a spirituality
program you're like this is the program
but then it's still a program itself
after you beat all the levels and
accumulated all the wisdoms and all the
candies
and all the levels of consciousness
that spirituality itself that program
must self-deconstruct as well
to go back to their natural state that's
the difference between a natural state
and
this guy who's enlightened has halo on
his head
and this the natural state guy wouldn't
care he could be a porn star or a
prostitute
and he wouldn't care if people perceived
that as enlightenment or not
enlightenment
the formation of even spirituality
itself arose from
the realignment
to our true nature as
intelligent infinity endlessly
expressing itself
because we had the distortions of those
egoic
onion layers and that we became attached
to form and identity and separation and
trying to extract peace and happiness
rather than knowing our nature as peace
and happiness
and so spirituality formed as a word to
realign
people away from those egoic onion
layers towards god's love light unity
service to others and that's the whole
notion is once you know and you're
abiding
then you like frank said you're in this
natural state that's so harmonic that
there's no
impulse whatsoever for you to have to i
have to share my goal with people
it's it's only when a true
disciple that's confused comes and asks
you know what is the natural state
then you this darshan that's this
enlightenment transmission that just
naturally spontaneously creatively comes
through
to directly point them at exactly
what they are and also
to help them refine is we give these
metaphors
and symbolic analogies like
recognizing oneself as the sky in which
the thoughts and the perceptions and
emotions and beliefs appear and
disappear
and so you're the awareness sky that is
impersonal and eternal
and then you are actually the creator of
even
the sky itself and the clouds and so
you're the source of the infinite
possibility stream and so
to sort of recognize that
the whole of what we're talking about
is in itself
this perfection that's ineffable and yet
no words and and yet is so
important because you and i if there was
if if the people we were seeking to
learn from were just like
there is nothing that there was nothing
to do we we would be like
yeah yeah we're still very i i still
think it's very important to share
i think i think it all depends on if you
align with it or not like
if you have a resistance if you feel
authentic
doing that if it's aligned towards the
absolute then you can do anything you
want really
but when you're in line with the
absolute it's just there's very little
chance that you're going to hurt other
people that's why i say just do whatever
the [ __ ] you want just don't hurt other
people
but if you're like you can share if you
want you can share however form or
shape that you want uh it doesn't have
to be just oh
i can't share unless someone comes talk
to me because that's all spiritual ego
it's not really like that
either you know it's it's all about how
aligned you are
to truth when you do you know not just
sharing dharma but
anything because at the end of it
the source that vibrates into the
highest meditative states of godhead is
the same source that vibrates into a
tree
or a leaf there's more truth in
a branch from a tree or a leaf than
the entire paradigm of spiritual
knowledge because there really is no
such thing as spiritual knowledge
because enlightenment is the end of all
knowledge
you just abide in the not knowing
abiding in the not knowing is very very
difficult because the mind can
understand it's just like spirituality
is something that
you accumulate all this knowledge just
is great you came out all those
experiences all this inside but at this
end of the day if you don't throw all
that away and just be a [ __ ] tree
then you're still gonna have some
clinging and suffering
so the
simultaneity of
absolute ineffable
perfection mystery enigma
just simultaneously
with these maps symbols
analogies metaphors for those
that don't feel like i am a flower
growing towards the sun but they feel
like there's a mind
inside of the flower that is toiling
them around
from suffering to suffering that then
there's a way to go
and then that's what we're talking about
and then even then when you get to the
warm alignment then
again go through the process of the
absolute
absence of symbolization and
maps and meaning and all that
and then once you've really abided as
that as well
then recognize okay well there is
naturally spontaneously
will be a time when you will turn
and then serve those that do seek as
well
and then you can put on the back the
costume of all the different knowledges
of different spiritual traditions
or different lengths of perception of
how to experience the world perceptually
but then you just are not attached to
any of them
you're not attached to a certain school
or certain path or
or this experience is more true than
your experience
you sort of just detach yourself from
all of it you realize that all of it
is it but none of it is it at the same
time
that's when you transcend being a
non-being
the absolute in the relative
oh yeah i have this analogy but since we
love some analogy so much
i have one more analogy that you're like
the first the first stage is this you
the little boy and discover that you
have a penis
and then you discover that you have a
penis and you can't ejaculate and then
the third stage you discover that you
could [ __ ] a woman or two or three
whatever
and then the fifth stage or the fourth
or whatever you discovered that you
could [ __ ] the universe what the
universe is [ __ ] you
and the final stage enlightenment is
when the universe is [ __ ] itself
and then you sink into the natural state
which includes but transcends
all the other stages you can still fab
v1 or [ __ ] the universe
oh [ __ ] two girls or just you know be a
flower
it's the reflexivity that really matters
it's a reflexivity see a lot of people
get stuck in this idea of no self and
emptiness
yeah yeah because that's just one view
even non-duality is just one dimension
of life
when you first access it you think this
is it this is
well it is true but then once you let
that go you realize oh i
i never truly understood it until i let
it go and then now you have this
different lens
play with you can you can wear the lens
of a soft you can wear the lens of no
cell
you can wear the lens of whatever self
in between
but only when you let go of all the
different layers of the mind
can you comfortably put them on like a
wardrobe without being attached to it
truly being an invisible man who is
capable
of putting on any type of wardrobes and
costumes
and not feel any friction
i adore that that's so strong it's the
the process of let's start with
if even in the first place because
there are still quite
enlightened parents conscious
awake parents and also conscious awake
enlightened indigenous traditions
where they don't even allow in the first
place for the egoic layers of identity
like onion to to form in the first place
and where does the grow
yeah so you it's it's right away from
the beginning
it's true embodied knowledge
of being an expression of infinity of
firework
and being both that emptiness and all
form
and so that's beautiful to have that and
that's definitely a huge part of the
planetary pedagogy as we get to
our more awakened civilization now
in the 3d third density matrix
that we were born into
that when we talk about matrix we
reference things
like government politicians propaganda
economic machinery high fructose corn
syrup fast food
all these things that are like they're
the lockless
locks that anchor us lockless luck
and that our process like you described
it goes from a place of you can say that
the
like you said you little boy with a
penis and then you learn you can
ejaculate
and then you're like oh my gosh i can
have sex
and then there is the you transcend
again so this is a really important part
because most i would say most people are
at the place where they're having sex
they're really enjoying swiping on the
tinder and
and platforms where they can hook up
culture this type of stuff
i can hook up culture it's almost like
if you're doing something for approval
of another
like colleague in your work that's the
same thing
yeah just like your identity is based on
how the other party perceives you that's
perfect that's the part where you find
out you could have sex with people
that makes you happy and then you
realize you could have sex with the
entire universe while the universe is
[ __ ] you
and that's when you get into
spirituality in the pinnacle when the
universe [ __ ] itself and then you drop
all of that yes yes so
this is really a beautiful way to to
share this
frank this was really nice is that that
when we go
and we seek
to have bliss and peace
through our orgasms from
having sex and we get validation
as well my whole identity is based on my
costume
being validated by other costumes but we
don't both
these are when you're in the third
density you're not calling it costumes
because
you don't know that that eye is even
shared and so you think that these are
separate entities and whatnot and so
so what happens is then
you work into piercing that veilus veil
and getting to a point where you're like
wow this is the universe [ __ ] itself
this this is beautiful i can i can have
sex with the whole universe prana
even the word itself that life force
that comes
every single one of these inhalations is
so
dmte every single one of them
and so when we really tap into that
then we get to a point where i'm having
sex with the phytoplankton and the trees
of the planet as the whole oxygenation
of the planet is occurring and i'm
taking 20
000 of those per day and so then you're
getting into
more much more spiritual awakened states
and then
yes the universe [ __ ] itself and then
realizing that
that whole infinity expressing itself
endlessly and then the natural state as
is written in the banner as frank
described
is when you drop all all of the
categorizations
and instead you're able to like a ninja
like a jedi playfully
put on these different lenses and jump
between
you know one day if you're feeling
spontaneous go and
[ __ ] a girl [ __ ] victory after you
[ __ ] go go into your god my state
oh simultaneously maybe keep [ __ ] you
got my state
and then afterwards you just yeah be a
treat
yeah go yeah go in and so this is
i would say that the natural state is
sort of what happens
when you drop in many ways when you drop
your point of view
and you drop ideas and you drop
symbolization and what you do
is you go on a walk and as you're on the
walk
you surrender to the absolute flow
and what happens is you're walking and
then you see a flower and you stop and
you
yes you enjoy this you enjoy that aroma
of the flower and it's
and it's beautiful in your action this
is like
a little kid that's it's like it's like
being a little kid an old man
and a monkey more so than being an old
spiritual person
[Laughter]
and and that and this is the thing is
that and then
after the flower that there's the
the the person that's chilling on
on their bike and right on the sidewalk
where you're walking
and that you guys look at each other and
you smile and at that point many people
if they haven't you know played around
with this
sort of ability to navigate through this
they they may just simply walk right
past
and you can walk right past if that's
what arises but
it's the confrontation of the souls
i've really enjoyed that a lot is when
you in a sense you stop
and you do post smile you're like you're
feeling that
peace and bliss of the natural state and
the
person even though they might not be at
such an elevated state
they become like you know to me this
happened a couple days ago they said
they're like you were meant to show up
in my life
like i have been wondering about this
exact thing you are meant to show up
and to talk to me about this natural
bliss and peace
and so that's something really important
is undergoing this confrontation of the
souls
and because that's ultimately what this
is about is about
every single one of these infinite
fireworks
undergoing a relational process with
itself to awaken to its true blissful
peaceful
amazing nature yeah yep
yep and i love that that was a really
good breakdown
from you and that again if we can
take the these different
layers lenses and be able to swiftly
effortlessly like a jedi navigate
through them
then we're really in a deeper more
embodied less driven by
one of those distorted kinks it's almost
like the distorted kinks can sometimes
drive when you get stuck at one of those
levels
and then or with one of those lenses you
get stuck with one of the lenses
like there's nothing to do and nowhere
to go
and nobody to be and nobody here and
this is just a dream
you don't exist that's become one of the
most
common like neo advaita like this is it
this is the end this is the truth and
then what happens is
when somebody parrots that message
because of mimesis where mimetic
creatures
that then they wonder why do i still
suffer why do i have anger why do i have
malevolence towards other people because
you haven't had stream entry yet
you haven't even entered into your own
stream of clouds appearing and
disappearing you haven't become
aware of awareness and so you have to
recognize that that
this is what we're talking about your
ability to navigate
all of that right right
so i would say there are three levels to
uh realization first is
intellectual and second is an experience
the third is a realization right
so a lot of times we hear so many
spiritual talks and we only understand
intellectually
and we don't have any experience of it
even with experience people can tend to
get stuck there because without any
realization
the experience doesn't get locked in
because a realization
is something that transcends both the
experience and the intellectual
understanding
but includes them both i would say
realization is something like a
permanent shift
in perception a permanent shift in
how you are being in the world exactly
we embody the war it's very
visceral it transcends the physical and
the spiritual it transcends experience
so we get confused a lot of the times
between
experience and realization and also
between uh intellectual understanding
and experience there's so many spiritual
talks out there i was talking to one of
my clients yesterday i was like how's
your meditation going
and then he was like you know i do i
meditate here and there but why
meditate when i can just listen to uh
non-duality lectures on youtube
i'm like you can if you're doing like
self inquiry on top of that as a
supplement
but if you only listen to lectures if
you only read books that's like
back to the gym analogy that's like
looking at a workout program or watch
ronnie call my workout without you ever
having to step into the gym
and grow muscles yourself that's the
difference
and then you have realization which is
taking that muscle
okay now i have a lot of experiences
building muscle now i have a great i
have a six-pack
i'm strong now how am i going to carry
this new mitsu this new physique this
new
uh consciousness into the world and live
as an embodied being being embodied in
the world
while carrying this newfound physique
mitsu consciousness whatever that's
realization
that's why i like talking to you man
because like you're like you're not just
stuck in just a spiritual paradigm you
have all these different
like nudes notes that you're just
connecting
i mean i'm cool with talking to people
who are only spiritual too
but like there's a lot more to there's a
lot there
you know there it's a lot more nuanced i
guess this whole thing is a lot more
nuanced not just spirituality but
in reality itself it's a multi-faceted
jewel
and the unfoldment of it depends on how
what light you use to filter to what
lens
it's it's infinite i was reading uh do
you know we can sign the the philosopher
the
luke wig wickenstein the great uh
australian philosopher you know him
right yeah i was going to talk to you
about how i wrote that down too because
so maybe we can pull out the tractatus
and we can read a couple of lines i
think
wickenstein is extremely he's on the
verge of enlightenment he's playing with
his mind and brave
logic so much that any moment he could
just completely bust through it
but he didn't or maybe he did i don't
know but based on
like his writing and the way he lives
his lives i don't think he's gotten
there but
he is so close so the tractatus
is basically the only book that he
published
his aim and goal of this book is to
answer
and demolish all philosophical debates
arguments statements discourses
in the last thousands of years since
plato and how
is he going to go about doing that so he
wrote this little book a tiny little
manual called the tractatus
and then i think we should let people
see what the treatators look like
there's just like the little axioms
there it's not even like a book
it's almost like it's just like a
statement after statement after
statement it doesn't happen even have
sentences
there there there we go the war that
that that's it that's one two three four
five that's what the book is consists of
basically he comes up with this little
axioms based on his perfection and his
training in logic at mathematics
and then he comes no one can understand
this but i don't i don't understand it
but i understand what he's trying to do
so number one the world is everything
that is the case number two
what is the case effect is the existence
of states of affairs it's almost like a
zhang koan it's almost like a like a
haiku or something
very mystical actually he's had a few
mystical experiences
but he's not like abiding in it and a
lot of this
comes from his mystical experiences but
he filters
his mystical experiences through this
lens of like
super hardcore logic and mathematics and
it's just it just
shows you how like infinite ways that
that can manifest itself even in someone
whose mind is completely scientific and
logical
he's going after the same thing the most
interesting
sentence in this whole book which is
premise again is to demolish
transcends all philosophical inquiries
from plato to socrates
to aristotle to uh i don't know
heisenberg assad rousseau every single
philosopher he wants to demolish and
transcend
the very last sentence of this book
pull it out let's read that last thing
that has been my favorite quote since i
was like 18.
but i never understood what that really
truly meant until
very recently that i truly understood
what he's trying to do
i even put that last quote in my tinder
profile and back then would have like
zenga that was my
like you know the quote in my headline
the last quote
the last one the last sentence of this
very short book
what is it maybe i can search it what
cannot be speak of must be passively
silenced
there you go that's the last one this
one
the main thesis right yeah where's
one cannot speak therefore one must be
silent so yeah what cannot be speak of
must be passive in silence
that's the last sentence of this book
this short little book that aims to
transcend our philosophy
and if you truly understand that
sentence this book itself must
also self-deconstruct so it's a ladder
that you used to climb
and when you get to the other side of
the door you throw it away so
vikingstown will tell you
if you're still reading my book and
trying to understand what it means you
have to understand my book
so this book could be kind of
metaphorical to the whole
system or whole paradigm the whole game
of spirituality once you truly
understand spirituality
is self-deconstruct but funny thing is
after like 20 years of saying nothing he
went back to like
he became like a kindergarten teacher or
something became a gardener or something
he still came back
and had a new system of philosopher even
after he said oh i have nothing more to
say he still came back and still wanted
to share and be creative he realized
after 20 years i haven't seen this
am i identical yeah yeah
that that that kind of like the process
is is there for every
everything it's not it's not just in
spirituality even someone who is into
philosophy he realized okay i have
defeated philosophy i have nothing more
to say because all these philosophers
because he basically he's using language
to eat itself this whole book is
language eating itself so he said that
the reason why all these
previous philosophers are always arguing
and never get to the bottom of the truth
of what is the mind what is
reality what is athlete they can never
get to the bottom of it why because
they're using language
they're using the mind to understand the
mind which cannot be possible you
understood that one
so he said okay i'm just gonna try i'm
gonna throw away language throw away the
mind throwing everything it's very very
similar to spiritual awakening
you cannot use the mind to understand
the mind because you're thinking about
something still discussing it you
haven't truly understood it
he understood that
[Music]
[Laughter]
in many ways yeah this
excites me because what
was expressing
was very much like what kirk girdle
was also expressed yes yeah
and which which douglas hofstetter has
picked up on and is now strange looping
yeah and we have
donald hoffman also taking a lot of
these
ideas and bringing them forth and
we have eric weinstein as well
taking a lot of this bringing forth it's
it's exciting to see
the
more logic
and science and rationality based
approaches
also as you shared with us the reason
why we came to this
as an exploration was because you gave
this idea of this
lattice work and that
when one does not
get stuck in a specific
dogmatic parroting style
of behavior pattern
with the nature to reality what they do
is they
open themselves up to the process of
actually being able to
as you learn about what truly the
bitcoin white paper and satoshi nakamoto
and peer-to-peer
frictionless exchange of value truly is
and when you also open yourself up to
dna and the code of life and
understanding atcg
understanding transcriptomics and
proteomics metabolomics when you really
get to a place of when you start putting
all these things up along with
you know the heart sutra and all this
other great stuff up in this lattice
where
you become a jedi
you just swiftly navigate frictionlessly
and blissfully and playfully and
peacefully and
you can put on all these different
lenses
and that is josephine the coat of many
colors that
is the chameleon consciousness that is
that
what the
the cosmic octopus exactly this day
feels like
if i could be one spiritual animal to
represent this thing it will be a cosmic
octopus
i think we did we talked about that last
time as a metaphor we did a little and
do you remember the emoji that i sent
you
yes yes just recent really recently yeah
that was perfect that that was the emoji
yeah yeah
for those who uh who didn't listen to
the last one or who hasn't
uh heard me spoken about the cosmic
octopus
well it's basically just feels like
every sensation every everything
experiences your tentacle even your
mitsu
it's an octopus it's a cosmic octopus
with no center
so even your your mind and your body
your mind your body is just one of the
tentacles in this infinite reality we're
just constantly shape-shifting
dependent codependent rising with the
environment and the mind of the
octopus is the body octopus is totally
non-dual
it thinks with this entire being entire
body it flips itself
inside out so that the language and the
visualization and thought
of the octopus is one with the
physicality of the body
that's what's magical about the octopus
and the octopus itself
is one with the environment because it's
however he thinks it's not just
accordance to the mind body but in
accordance with the environment
so the environment the sea the ocean the
mind the body of the octopus are one
and they become immutable that's what
happened to the the enlightened being at
the last picture
he becomes invisible only when he wants
to
then he can emerge and ejaculate his uh
cosmic calm like the
octopus like ejaculating this the uh the
the ink
and just you know throw his cosmic
spiritual metaphysical comet people and
they might affect people if you want
check this out to synthesize
to synthesize with the cosmic octopus
the
villi inside of the gastrointestinal
tract right so
so each one yeah you get bigger
make it bigger yeah so in a sense
each one of these
is like um each one of these is like the
you and i these costumes right so these
are like the fireworks of intelligent
infinity or like these tentacles in the
cosmic octopus
and so what you're doing is you are that
which from this intestinal tract
is what is absorbing all of this
beautiful delicious experience of this
creation that is dreamed and that is
exploratory and that is lila
and that is in relation to all of the
other
fireworks villi tentacles and so there's
all these really great
sort of analogies to use in
the in the process of of discussing this
and i would also like to loop this
back to what frank mentioned along with
the lattice work
what's mission critical is the actual
realization so as we said at the
beginning of
the program you're already it
yep it's already
it and that's a beautiful teaching but
it's one of the layers
another one of the lenses layers is that
realization is the process
of becoming aware of awareness itself
rather than having this mind that is
on these layers of identity and trying
to extract
peace and happiness and all this type of
stuff rather
align yourself with the god's love light
that is already omnipresent
at play rather than the layer of your
costume that you're attached to
trying to prove and get validation and
creating malevolence and suffering this
type of stuff so
it's mission critical to recognize that
there are
these lenses that you can wear in the
process and that realization
is what we talked about simultaneously
so this is why the process people wonder
sometimes they're like
well why even do these you know gym
repetitions and when now what's the
point of doing repetitions well
for me for example five years ago till
now
it went from a place of being
totally unaware totally unconscious
totally algorithmic
totally scripted to now in a place
of bliss peace sovereignty
and just in
the feeling of true ineffable perfection
whereas
you know even a year ago even a year ago
the feeling of ineffable perfection
there was not a causeless joint and if
an
imperturbable piece at the stage that
it's at today
and so that's the whole thing of why
abide is that
is that it richens it deepens it deepens
yeah it deepens even after you make the
quantum shift
after even after you light the wood on
fire permanently there is
always going to be more deeper and
deeper stuff that you can explore
uh not just through spirituality or
meditation itself but through other
fields
um see that's why the the the tentacles
like well i can be looking
i can experience the cloud right now or
the wind or the burst they're all my
tentacles
and then looking at you it's the
tentacle looking at a piece of art this
is tentacle
looking at words are tentacles too it's
not like one tentacle is more true than
the other
it's like you know the absolute can
manifest itself into concepts too
it's not like oh no concept i'm not
gonna read any books i'm only gonna stay
in there now
you know what i mean then you're already
limiting yourself to whatever it is that
that that that's that's why you always
have to go meta and by meta i don't
exactly mean going a level above
although it's kind of like that it's
it's more like just
dissolving yourself eating yourself from
the inside like the stink biting some
tail that's what i really
really what i mean by going meta because
a lot of people when they i used to do
that when i was going mad out with the
mind
i used to have one level and i would
come up with another level to look at
the level
and then another level to look at that
level but then you just adding on more
and more layers
right true going meta is like the
strange loop where
whatever it is the case eats itself so
not just the philosopher that we talked
about earlier wittenstein or
you know the bunch of artists and sort
of scientists and uh
uh intellectual you mentioned but even
in spirituality
it's talking about the same thing buddha
says even emptiness is empty you think
you realize emptiness
even that's empty go beyond the beyond
go transcend the transcendence oh
i'm sitting in the transcendence well
you transcend the transcendence
right and even um
transcendence must eat away itself to
truly descent
you have people like ramana mahashi he
says things like use the mind to
dissolve the mind
same deal they're all talking about the
same thing it's like the
the goddamn thing you know the system
needs to eat away itself
to really understand the system it needs
to eat away itself
yeah it sounds like there's an ice cream
truck playing in the background
of your it's actually a um
music music it's trash crash car it's
trash truck
oh it's a trash truck that plays ice
cream truck music
that's great
we should do that in the us taiwan is
great
we should do that in the us we should i
should have trash trucks playing ice
cream truck music in the us
we can have our little uh get together
in there
[Laughter]
podcast in there and we can have people
come and you know we have a little
fun guy in there i put cosmic octopus in
the banner for us because
it's really deepening its
poignancy as an analogy here in this
costume as well
because when you when you quote
experience especially the shift
from the 3d matrixy third density
human to the fourth density love
heart chakra opening when you experience
that
what it enables you to do if you really
train this you can really become like
those cosmic octopus tentacles
and you can in a sense jump between
all of these unique aspects of that
cosmic unity christ consciousness of all
being love light inter
playing with itself infinity [ __ ]
itself and so what you can do
is you can do things like for example
i like to do this fun exercise there's
two that i'll
give one of them is it's pretty simple
at any point on the planet
there are approximately 1
billion people asleep at any time on the
planet
and so what you can do is you can tap
in to that collective
that is asleep that one billion of the
eight billion that are asleep in the
seven billion that are awake
and so out of the seven billion that are
awake probably about
five or so billion of them are in the
process of doing something in the
in the machinery and economic machinery
political machinery and then maybe
another two or so billion of them are
either in the morning or at night in
their cycle so more relaxed type thing
so tap into that
effect and then another one to if you
really want to kind of play at these
higher levels is you begin to hold on
to beyond your awareness
to a more impersonal
awareness so you begin holding
simultaneously you can do this with like
two people
and begin holding the as you have a
conversation with somebody you're
holding
both your awareness and their awareness
as the i
the great i am and you're holding it for
both
and then you expand it out to three four
five six expand that out to a whole city
expand that out to the whole planet
and then what you get if you really want
to
start playing at these kind of bigger
leagues of being able to tap into even
awareness
itself as an attribute
what you can do is you can begin
visualizing things like
this where you begin
taking what is this last attribute of
awareness
and i can see if i can get a nice little
zoom on that there we go
so you are source that makes
the witnessing of infinite transients
and so can you visualize
the process of you being that which
is this all-inclusive awareness that is
all over the planet watching witnessing
creating
playing all this cool stuff on the
planet
and doing that endlessly with different
creations different civilizations
different form different costumes
all this type of stuff and so this is
these are the little
styles of fun like gym repetitions as
activities that we can do and
they're very in a sense under
the
they're not really in the spiritual
nomenclature nobody really gives you
this example of
this is why frank and i also resonate
really deeply is because we both
care a lot about the visualization of
the nature
as well and when you do that
and this is you know stuff like
stuff like this is actually courtesy of
you know this like this is courtesy of
frank from
from six weeks ago right infinity
expressing itself you get
visualization visualizations like this
that help you a lot
in the process of recognizing your true
nature and there's
another couple in here that frank
passed along that are really strong this
one was one of the recent ones as well
let me close the window really quick
it's getting noisy perfect
you go do that so this is
there we go this is another one that
you know that we recently made to
synthesize with nature because you have
the hummingbird that comes and sucks the
nectar
out of the flower yeah the same way that
the same way that humans suck the nectar
out of the big bang
that's amazing so there's ones like that
and then there's
you know this is one that also
frank passed along that was
why you just described that little
exercise um
you said the contemplation that you did
where you kind of expand your awareness
first to cover
the other person is if you guys have the
same awareness and then to two people
the entire planet to the whole universe
and then you said the next step is to
even go beyond that
and realize that this even that
awareness has a source has the
unmanifested
and then that i mean i'll manifest it
can manifest awareness or it can
manifest in
other different types of lenses of
perception and that's exactly what we
talked about earlier too it's like that
for that
that initial step of expanding your
awareness to love to unity consciousness
that's sort of that the the love step
the the jesus christ christ
consciousness step
the oneness and then you go to the
emptiness step where you realize that
you go to that
what i call the the dark light
of the absolute which manifests both
darkness and lightness right
which manifests not just infinite uh
christ consciousness but everything else
so you go back and forth between those
two extremes that's why we talked about
earlier you want to share
you want to go into silence you want to
share you want to go into silence
you know one step is absolute infinity
as i call it and the next step is
absolute nothingness
but it's the merging of the two it's a
simultaneity of the two
that is the realization that's it yeah
that is the realization
yes it is and that's what the mystics
the sages have been pointing to
and that you will you will never
come to the end of all of the creative
possibilities
that you are you talking about and you
will
also never be any
of those you will always be formless
emptiness as well and so
yeah when we say go beyond birth and
death go beyond coming and going
we mean be the ineffable perfection
that is this
yeah and the only thing you can see
there's nothing to say about the state
except for oh this is a table that's a
chair right there it's
just so simple yeah
yeah peace the and this is also we
wanted to share this
with you guys also
let's share our boom boom
the sculpture of god yeah that's a good
one yeah
the the first the first reaction the
first thought that i had when i came
across this picture was
during my entrance to stream entry on my
second retreat
so i was meditating for uh at a gominka
retreat 12 hours a day on the 10th day
the last sit on the 10th date i was like
i knew something was happening i just it
was happening
i was like i have to sit through this
sit and however long it takes i'm going
to stay there by myself
even after the going card discourse if i
have to
i just knew that i had to break through
something here i could feel it so i was
sitting there after like three hours
i could see this image sort of emerging
just from the distance
at first it was very small it looks
almost exactly like this at first it was
very small
and then it became bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
that's when i was
already sort of doing self inquiry sort
of abiding in awareness
phase that's what allows this manifest
because i was already pulling away from
the franking
entity from the the meditator entity
even
and this thing emerged and i was like
the first reaction i had was like holy
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] creepy
it's creepy because first of all it's so
familiar it's almost like
that's it's almost like that's home or
like that that's always been me
[Laughter]
at the same time it's extremely alien
there's a paradox there that's the
paradox
i was just frightened i was fighting for
two reasons because that
do i really want to die do i really want
to merge with the absolute or god
do i really want to see my true nature
which is why we run away from
the inward path here's the quote that we
can put out everything that we do in
life
as separate individuals is to avoid the
nothingness that you are is to avoid
this this is nothingness which is why
it's also everything
and then i was like everything that i
knew and experienced
throughout my whole lifetime and from
everybody is in there
that's the potentiality of unmanifested
which is the same as the manifested
is this is this it everything we do in
life is to avoid nothingness
and nothingness that we are that we are
let me
at that point i was like i could just
stop meditating
and then just you know go back to my
life or i could merge with this thing so
this thing
it's almost like the screen the the
let's call it the screen the screen of
god
and then this is the screen of frank
which is already detaching itself from
itself
that's why the screen of god could
appear uh
in the perception of the screen of frank
but then they actually the same thing
so i was like once i realized that man i
have to do this i don't know when i'm
getting another chance because
after like 10 days of meditation for 12
hours i you know this thing came up i
was like
you know i don't know why i'm gonna get
another chance to die
getting closer and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and then
i was i blanked out i i thought i could
enter it
that was my original um initial thought
i thought i could enter it
and go into econo and experience god
unity or whatever
but then that wasn't the case i totally
blinked out and that is the
the succession right there it's in a
succession there's just nothing it's
almost like a few friends says
taking away from the the cinema of your
life if there's still something it's not
it
so i completely blanked out there was no
experience at all there's not even an
experience of nothing or god nothing
which is almost like i fell asleep but
in a very high concentrated state
that's death right there and then i came
back in
and then i just got sort of got popped
out of the god
of the godhead um and then there was
this like whole body bliss and
ever since after that i knew i entered
stream entry the first
stage of awakening according to a
theravada buddhist tradition
now i used to pretty attached to those
paths but not anymore but just
in accordance with the theravada
tradition after that event was when
everything just goes
exponentially faster and faster and then
my perception after that i just shifted
i could feel like you know my perception
was panoramic 360. but it was still a
bubble that where
i still haven't broken through awareness
yet so at the time i was like
my head was my head got really big but
there was still a distortion
there was still the awareness i could
still sense a bubble so that bubble has
to expand expand and expand and the
character has to continue strength
strengthening the secrets to continue
string strengthening until the secret is
nothing and there's no even bible
awareness there's not even consciousness
there's no way that the self can hide
not even in awareness not even
consciousness not even nothing
so that was my first reaction when i saw
that picture you brought me back the
memory of
entering stream entry and then uh yeah
that that is the
the sculpture of the absolute
that is your that is a depiction even
though you can't really depict what your
true nature is
um and by the way
from the communion that i've had
as well validates also
as well as the communion from the people
that i've talked to
and featured on the show around their
realization
so that's really validating the many
paths
one end and also
that when you asked me a little bit ago
to also unpack
and describe what it is to transcend
even the all-inclusive awareness itself
it is this it's becoming
the nothingness that we
ex that we purposely are
avoiding because the nature
is the perfect
of the eternal fire working away from
nothingness
the whole thing is infinity expressing
itself
away from nothingness endlessly
fractaling just like
this image the sculpture of god is
also in many ways
it is as we had when we first
pulled up the program
it is like you see when you look up
our homies over at maths town
these guys are the homies because it
really is this this is what we're
talking about
we're talking about stuff like this this
being it this being infinity
endlessly fractaling expressing itself
as
your unique costume endlessly
your costume frank's costume the eight
billion costumes right now
the next creation that has different
vehicles that has a different
civilization that has a different
history that has a different rock
orbiting
a star that doesn't even have rocks
orbiting stars that doesn't even have
nervous systems it doesn't even have dna
it has all this different you can never
come to the
end and you will always be something new
you will always be something
unique yet you're also nothingness
yes yes yeah and so so get used to
you know benoit mandelbrot has
this incredible math that then we turn
into the visualization that is as close
as we can
right now and frank and i are aiming to
collaborate on
creating visuals that even help us
recognize
not only this but also this specific
expression
of our creation and then going beyond
that as well
and so just you know tap into stuff like
this
and it will uh enable you like we talk
about this a lot on the show but
if you really just do simple stuff like
if you contemplate
simple words like contemplate here's
here's a very short list you have
the automaton which gives rise
fractals of infinity it's the
inconceivable infamous
inevitable that gives rise even to those
to that to the animation
right yeah exactly you are
that which inevitably gives rise to this
infinite possibility yes yes correct and
that's why when you have people like
nisargadza the maharaja
he would endlessly he would refuse
whenever there would be any games of
identity being played he would say
you are that and siddhar meshwar would
also
say this who is his guru that as you
think
so you are so you're going to play the
game of identity you're going to be your
onion layers
i'm going to only be the source of
infinite possibility
that's my nature that's who i am that's
what this is
and so i am that and i am not what you
think
is this body and so this form and so
when you contemplate even
intellectually intellectually as frank
indicated
you can work your way like gym
repetitions up to the realized
to experience and to real into
realization
because these are your words when you
look up things like infinity when you
look up things like eternity when you
look up things like automata
and recursion what you realize is that
we are
that these are the words that we are
when you look at the way that a cell
hits a cell checkpoint
and then undergoes mitosis when you look
at the way that
two humans come together and reproduce
to make a human which then finds another
human to reproduce make a human
just like the oak tree drops an acorn
that then makes more oak trees that drop
more acorns it's just
recursion it's automata go to the big
bang
poof and what happens automata self
making
self producing endlessly and guess what
cycle again ask sir roger penrose who
won the nobel prize in physics in 2020
says
that where we are going is where we came
from
we it's a cyclic cosmology even the
world's leading
physicists themselves which is really
exciting for the synthesis of science
and spirituality
yeah what were we talking about earlier
about the the symbols that the logos and
the animation that you showed us with
the loop in the background itself thing
yes god
that doesn't just apply to space that
also replies to time because time and
space are the same fabric einstein said
that himself
um is that that the past and the future
and the present are just persistent
illusions
even he understood that without the
direct experience of it just through
equations
so that infinite loop that i always tell
people i always like try to illustrate
the people
right snake biting its own tail the
universe eating itself or this picture
whatever
that also applies to time because if you
think about
it that loop if you visualize that loop
as a four-dimensional space-time
whatever is the case when you are born
until you die
is the case there is some okay on the
spiritual path
sometimes i tell people whatever isn't
there since the beginning of your birth
until you die or even before your birth
because it's gonna be experienced by
other people
or even after you die isn't it so if you
loop that thing from the beginning of
your birth
whatever it is that stays constant since
the beginning
of your birth until until the moment of
now until the moment you die
there's a loop and within this loop
forms sort of shape-shift inside it so
it's almost like
in this if you abide in this eternal
loop it's almost it almost feels like
whenever you think about the past
it's the same as thinking about the
future
the past memory it really feels like it
hasn't happened because the new group
everything is happening but nothing's
happening when you think about the
future
it seems like either it could already be
passed or it doesn't even exist
so it's like the past and the fusion and
present are loses meaning the sequential
events of past your present losses
meaning
and even the now even the power of now
is empty because there really is no now
because now it's co-dependent rising
through past and future yeah
never came the past sorry if the i got
[ __ ] up the class never came
that is kind of true okay let's go back
to the conventional level for a little
bit if the future will never come
and if the past already dead it will
never you know arise again then the
future cannot be
sorry the president cannot be said to be
exist either because they're culturally
rising
because you can still suffer in the in
the power of now actually
you free up a lot you free up a lot of
stuff in the now if you only
abide in and now free up a lot of stuff
but in fact if you take now to be the
new ground a new static thing would just
be like oh there's only the now
you can still suffer in the now but when
deconstructing it now it's almost like
deconstructing awareness
see the self is not the cheeky con that
it could abide it could
hide itself in awareness and same thing
as hiding itself in the power of now
but once constructed dissolve even
awareness when the self completely
dissolves when there's
nothing nowhere to hide when it's just
free flowing uh
even the now ceases to be meaningful
because the now in awareness almost
simultaneously exists one from the
perspective of space
and the other from the perspective of
time
once that last bag of self is dissolved
there's no
now to abiding there's no awareness to
find solace in it's just
inconceivable yeah but so at the same
time it's so simple it's so ordinary
and that is the more orderly something
is the more normally something is the
more
magnificent and more divine something is
it's just like looking reach your
documentary like
you watch the way the animals move and
you're like that's
how i'm moving too you watch how the the
wind blows
trees and how the flowers build me like
i'm in the same force of nature as all
that
right so that's why i've been watching a
lot of uh
animal planet document or nature
documentaries lately but see the
non-duality lineman is very very
interesting in the sense that
it is like kind of like going back to
like the primordial soup of nature
so it's just like exact same thing as
the lions and the cheetahs and the
trees and flowers and the birds but at
the same time
as humans see i wouldn't call animals
enlightened
because we they don't have the
metacognition to realize that
so in a sense non-duality enlightenment
is a combination or is the the
paradoxical
uh accumulation of something that's
extremely primal
something that's totally in the natural
state as natural as nature
and something that's totally alien
something that's totally like advancing
technology
something that's totally futuristic
because then really non-duality is
pretty new
even though it's the clinical natural
state it's it's something that's
just starting to pick up right now in a
modern society so in a sense it's
something that's
extremely primal and it's the force of
nature where animals are kind of
enlightened
but it takes a a a modern human being
who has a
this new organ that is the brain to
recognize it
so it's the combination of both the
advanced
the the alien the the new the uh
the technological the stuff that we
talked you talk about a lot you know
with those science stuff and the primal
the nature
it's the combination of the two that
makes sense and this is what
frank describes you have the earth
fractaling out so naturally look at the
hydrological cycle
it is so beautifully
smooth and abiding as
the effortless
infinite fractal and being the flower
that effortlessly blossoms towards the
sun that has
its unique aroma which is why
you have a unique costume is because
you're a unique firework of the infinite
and because of that you have a unique
aroma you have a unique
gift to bring and and when you begin
synthesizing the eastern non-dual
oneness with the western beautiful
individuation that's when you start to
actually get more towards the true
nature
rather than one or the other it's not
this or that it's always simultaneous
and like a jedi be able to navigate
between them
when you talk to people that are a lot
more non-dual and oneness oriented
maybe there's a way to very peacefully
and gracefully add a little bit of nice
individuation when you talk about people
that are hyper individuated
you can peacefully gracefully add a
little bit of that unity that
oneness as well that's a really good
statement that the east and the west
right the eastern
the synthesis of the east and the west
but then that
like i said before that is the modern
that that's a modern phenomena
that arose only after human civilization
that must
also be synthesized with nature with the
primordial super of the natural state
so it's the merging of all that yeah
because you could technically say like
animals are enlightened but not they're
not
really enlightened even though they're
the natural state because they don't
have the metacognition to recognize that
yes it's almost like you need to put a
brain on a flower
yeah yeah there you go right there you
go
you put a bray on a flower yeah and then
you have this
flower garden with all of the different
flowers and all the different aromas
yeah and and they're all unique designs
that are different colors and aromas and
forms and some
have a little bit more of those thorny
on this down the stems um
and that's a really good way to
you know i i i'm just like visualizing
the field
i'm visualizing like i'm in a gardener
and then there's a field of flowers and
each flower has like its own brain
and different colors it's like little
little brains on the flowers and a whole
field of different
flower brains that is this that is
this and for some reason
we with our self-awareness and choice
we have the ability to become attached
to what is the distortions the twists
the identity
the attachment to form seeking peace and
happiness externally all the carrots of
maya
we have that ability and because of that
that's where the suffering the
malevolence all these things
come from and yet at the same time
we have what is very clearly this
architectural visionary
transcendent protocol transformation
that's happening where we have precision
consciousness
awakening we have the precision
protocols of decentralization synthetic
biology
and as frank listed a moment ago
everything we're building with
artificial general intelligence and
neuralink and indistinguishable virtual
realities the metaverse all the stuff
all of that is the natty state
yes there's nothing but the natural
state so
at the level of the absolute nothing
unnatural about stabilization at all
because there's no duality between
what's natural and what's unnatural
what's real what's not real
so from the ultimate perspective
everything is a natural state
in 1945 the same
dropping of right at the end of world
war
ii the same dropping of bombs on
hiroshima nagasaki and the unlocking
of the nuclear weapons planetarily
happening at the same time as albert
hoffman
uncovered lsd that
is the ascendant descent happening
simultaneously like we talked about
earlier this episode
that is that the ascent and descent
happening simultaneously
and in the ultimate analysis the ascent
and descent are what
the natty state like we've been saying
yeah you have to break down to break
through
so like the process of awakening is very
very close to going through under
through uh psychosis actually
so like you know the the hiroshima it
blows away the entire civilization
almost not saying it's good or bad
you know not saying that it should have
happened because it gives rise for news
for lazy i'm not saying that i'm not
giving labels to it i'm just saying that
process in itself
is the same process of the mind when you
take lsd it destroys
all your previous beliefs and paradigms
and identities
and experiences and it gives birth to a
new thing
a new entity that's what happened not
just
hiroshima uh anytime at the micro level
macro level cosmic level
it's all going on somewhere all the time
even now moment by moment we're dying
we're dying we're
being reborn moment by moment you know
that's impermanence
you know what is reincarnation people
ask is there a reincarnation
i don't need to worry about if i'm gonna
exist after i die if
my soul is gonna be reincarnated after i
die what's right now
is reincarnation what it is right now is
you dying moment by moment at the same
time you're giving birth to yourself
mumbai moment
then you that make up who you are now is
gone one millimeter second ago
like a movie
but at the same time when you zoom into
the movie frame it's completely static
so impermanence can only code dependent
rising with
complete eternalism yes and then you go
yes so you go beyond eternalism and
idolism
you go beyond permanence and
non-impermanence if something did the
opposite is also there just like reset
your ascending descent simultaneously
and that's why in the ultimate analysis
we keep saying
when you go beyond impermanence and
eternalism when you go beyond coming and
going when you go beyond
birth and death when you go beyond
absolute infinitude and absolute void
shunya emptiness
you just are
and that is ineffable perfection
yeah is everything everything that's
said before it belongs to the mind
the mind just tries to understand but
there is nothing to understand really
there's nothing to understand
i mean you can play around with concepts
that's fine but but at the deepest level
if you recognize the fact that
none of this none of the intellectual
things that we talk about
really are are really it i really
i mean it is the manifestation of it
like we said before but yeah you have to
send that to people to see that you know
what i mean it's like you have to you
have to understand that
all the mental stuff all the concepts
all the analogies are not it you have to
throw it away
before you can come back and wear them
like costumes if you are
in it if you're if you're still in it if
you're still in the minds
thinking to yourself oh uh this my stuff
uh is it too
everything natural is also unnatural if
you have a completely make that quantum
jump out of it you're just
kidding no he's just kidding yourself
yeah and you're going to keep
toiling as the flower trying to grow
towards the sun but going into this
identity that form yes yes
yes yes that's it which you can call
also the natty state if you want
but we also know that those are
distortions
even the distortions the kinks the
twists are
the natty state yet also they are
distortions king's twists you're in it
that can realign to
what is bliss peace
god's love light endlessly at play as
leela and to know oneself as
beyond coming and going to just
rest and relax drop
your specific point of view that you
have to insert
into everything that you do drop
that drop it and
relax into the ineffable
perfection that
this is and do that with friends
that know their true nature as well
surround yourself that's why it's called
satsang it's called truth community
and why is it called sadhana the
disciplined process of doing things like
satsang of abiding
is that as you do that more and more
often
and this is why at the shift into
permanent alignment that i was
just that bentino massaro and his team
had a really
radically transformative container that
they put together
very alchemical for all of the attendees
including myself
huge shift into permanent alignment and
guess what they have the opportunity to
do that daily they have their satsang
and sadhana daily they're purifying
themselves daily really hyper
refining those nuanced impurities that
are really
blind spots and difficult to see and
that in doing so the ascension is so
strong and then the anchoring
terrestrially of the architectures to go
from
that third density human to the fourth
density
love service to other christ
consciousness cosmic consciousness
unlocking
your fifth entity bro the fifth density
in the law of one is when you is when
you
balance wisdom with the love
because love tends to express itself
like um
over zealously as martyrdom and
you try and change everybody and give
them the love
and wisdom is the sort of graceful
balance of backing off
from needing to deliver love everywhere
i was like what we talked about earlier
that the merging of emptiness in form so
that's the fifth density is the merging
of the third and the fourth density okay
great what
is there there's a six density isn't it
yes because it's refracted
like the visible light spectrum so
so four and five merge into one like you
just described which is called unity
which is the sixth
and then that's also that's also the
density of the higher self
so that's the density where you have for
example the frank
that has already undergone this massive
creationary experience that is basically
doing chess with the third fourth fifth
density frank
the fixed density is kind of like just
embodying it individual or
is that this the sixth density is also
very
mirror consciousness so it's basically
where
you are so purely
love
this is what is said by darshan like
this is the direct enlightenment
transmission you are
just that you are literally just
the one heart you are just that
and that's what's meant by the mirror
and so that is that
and then seventh density is this god or
the quote like passport when you
basically
take everything that you've learned in
the creation
and then you take that and you use that
as the passport
into the next creation the oroboros so
eight
and one are the same because right it
goes
it's like the same pictures you go back
full circle except this time
you're it's completely different yet the
same the mountain is mounted again but
it's not out there as you perceive it
it's the mountain as the infinity
expressing itself
yeah is that kind of like same idea huh
totally totally
yeah every tradition is talking about
the same thing that's that's another
example of it
you look at even aliens talking about
the same thing yeah
and all of these especially when you
look at it like a
seven density ascension
or whether it's the ten steps or whether
it's whatever
it is that looks like that ascensionary
process
all that is trying to be described is
the stages
of the oroboros okay yeah yes
the stages of the snake eating its tail
right so the stages just like
in the sort of this is the this is the
most
recent sort of visualization that
put together of you know intelligent
infinity
right so you have intelligent infinity
that is this
you know it's like this is the this is
the source over here the source white
light
that refracts through the diamond that's
already around each of our necks which
is
awareness awareness is the diamond
around each of our necks
so it refracts through that first
attribute
of awareness and then this is the seven
density ascension
that we were just talking about rock
plant animal human this is where you go
service to others with love
with that fourth density heart chakra
then wisdom
balancing that out into unity and god
and then this is the god head the
mathematical attractor
why does it look like a solenoid well
this is because it is like
electromagnetic flux
that's the two poles in ascension this
is where science and spirituality get
synthesized into one
this is the attractor which is a
mathematics that a complex system
evolves towards and intelligent infinity
down here
looks a little bit like where you
fractal outward
you hit like in the parable of prodigal
son you hit a breaking point
and then you turn inward and that's
what's called yoga
finding union with what with god with
the absolute with intelligent infinity
and then from that place you woo way
like lao tzu said
effortlessly you firework individually
outward in pure service to others
and so this is the type of stuff that
we've been
playing around with so yeah it's all
talking about the same thing just like
the same picture at the last picture
it sort of it brings back the individual
it brings back the eye even though the
eye is empty
even though the individual the ego is
empty there's still going to be
manifestation
expression of the absolute through the
individual how else would they express
yourself
that's why i did really hardcore
non-dual teachings if you're not here
you don't exist it's what you do
it's i think it's great it's a great
step but what if you get stuck in there
it could be
potentially uh beta yep
by the way all of the great
most realized people that i know
like you and i having this conversation
and like both of us really respect
continuo a lot
a lot of the people that are
up here that a lot of people tune into
what they
say is because they carry the
perspective that you just shared
which is the simultaneity it's all
of those layers simultaneously like
lenses
and being able to navigate and i would
say another component to why people
respect people like that so much
is also because they
are they are the
purest manifestation of
light love leela they are
the divine play in its most purest form
they are both
the blissful giggle fest of
hee wee enjoy causeless joy
in imperturbable peace but they're also
balanced out with seriousness
earnestness and uh
being in service to helping people
realize
that net that natural state that true
yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think it's really important
to bring the individual back
into the into the the absolute because
see self and no self is not a duality
you see no difference at all ego
and non-ego between self and no self
between enlightenment and
non-enlightenment
between nirvana and samkara that's why i
think the buddha
or maybe someone who transcends him in
the buddha will feel more like a monkey
than a god or a human it would feel like
a some kind of entity that
is neither and both god monkey and a
human
yeah it's almost like your movement is
so natural you feel like a monkey like
an animal
but then you the consciousness that's
been expressed is so vast and so
intelligent
it feels outer space it feels like it's
from outer space it feels like it's from
some
some kind of ai fiction science fiction
reality so again it's a combination of
the two
that that gives rise to that's why
someone uh i think that one of the
brahmanas was challenging buddha asking
his three questions he's like hey bro
are you married god and the buddha said
neither i'm neither man or god
i'm awake
so that that entity that's awake is
neither being it's neither being or not
being
it's neither god or a human it's what it
is yeah
that's what it is never
ever ever ever
[ __ ] with the beautiful
individuated fireworks because
that is the prime mechanism
of intelligent infinity of endlessly
expressing itself
via the costumes the individuated
costumes never [ __ ] with that because it
is
our prime algorithm creatively is to be
able to rock
these costumes like this it's [ __ ]
dope
that's a lot of the times um see people
like gruber spyro and katelyn i want to
know what they're like
what are they me too like they're
they're they're presented in such a holy
way
that i want to see them as individuals
as well
you know i want to see the embodied
individuals now i want to see what i
could tell what's his favorite food
what's his favorite sex position
uh you know stuff like that you know
that if he can express that i i would
love him
more yeah yeah
a lot of times that's why i say the
spirituality paradigm is in itself
a kind of like a trap you have to play a
certain world
you have to talk a certain way to be
considered enlightened
it has to be expressed as well that's
why you see a lot of teachers they
commit
adultery or they abuse their students
because they're suppressing their
individuality
you're still a human being with
biological tendencies
even though it's all empty but on the
relative level on one plane
that is reality so a lot of teachers
they get into this non-dual state
and sometimes they would you know come
out with scandals and stuff like that
and i think it's because they haven't
really just like the priests that are
sort of like a rapey little kids
it's it's it's almost like they're their
their non-dual awareness is so vast
it's almost like they're their human
aspect of it either gets suppressed
overlooked or just you know they think
they shouldn't express it
right so but that's just another duality
and the appearance of the
holy spiritual teacher is
almost a cultural
dogma that has been it's been programmed
by the matrix
that if the spiritual teacher doesn't
look like that
then they're not enlightened so don't
trust them and
that's because if they they engage in
certain behaviors
yeah versus when you're in a sense
that's why
bentino uses in no sense he uses a cigar
as one of the ways of being able to be
like if you get triggered
by the cigar you are nowhere near
spiritual adept
you are nowhere near uh ready to get
through those egoic layers of identity
to try and know
your true nature if you're getting
triggered by that and very similarly
this is why the team you know every
single night we were going out
in the little rooftop at the
venue we were in costa rica and we were
dancing and playing and
being blissful and joyful and abiding
together
and we were doing that and this is the
type of stuff we would love to see the
planetary
spiritual leaders we would love to see
what they're like
when it comes to let's put on some music
let's
dance let's crack some jokes let's have
fun
and show people also that spirituality
is like frank's been saying
it is this very monkey-like natural
state as well
so that's what also trying to do i think
also with his uh he did
with his cars and his uh whatever else
that he did
check out these jokes
i take your trouble seriously but deep
inside i am giggling
and then there's there's this one too
that's funny man when i look at you
i am searching for a joke
you got that guy that's a troll man yeah
and
you're right it's a playboy yeah
you know what's funny though speaking of
osho uh i think at two or three weeks
ago i
had an out of body experience where i
was that was really one of the first
times that
was the only times i had a couple but
that was one of the only times where i
felt like
um i was speaking through my past lives
but even though from my perception right
now right now right here
i was just a dream was just like
something already happened when that
didn't happen
the oncological status of the validity
of it i don't really care but that
there was an experience like this i was
perceiving myself
in my past life that was one of the only
one of the only events where i felt like
i was really literally here physically
here in another lifetime or even right
now
if time is simultaneous i was there
right now but it was another space in
our dimension i was in oregon
and i was one of the followers of osho
i was literally there i was not asleep i
i started since i was in my bed but my
consciousness was there
literally i felt like i was physically
there that either either another
lifetime or right now
and then i was looking osho and he was
just like kind of like sitting there
doing his all shows thing he wasn't even
speaking he was
just silent but everyone else is like
clapping and worshiping like a god right
and i was one of the people but i didn't
watch him like a god i was just looking
at him in the eye and he looked at me
and i was like that's me and i'm him and
then because
this and i was like there's nothing
inside this man this man is a completely
empty house
he is the most ordinary man the most
magnificent but ordinary man in the
entire crowd
but everyone else was treating him like
he was some kind of a god
yeah but he was just that that is why
because he's
completely empty that's why people
project all kinds of stuff on him yeah
and i was i feel so sad because i was
like i knew what you're trying to do
i i could totally understand what you're
trying to do yeah
he looked at me too and he and then our
eyes just merged and i went to this like
[ __ ] dmt trip
it was [ __ ] crazy man perfect
what what a great way to put it is that
as we mentioned with
siddhar mishwar and sargata maharaj that
as
you think so you are so in this case you
have this audience
that is projecting god deity
and then you have the frank yang
character in the stream
that knows the nature
that osho in this case is
that very essence of that empty
playful blissful peacefulness
and that he recognizes that that is one
that the frank yang and the osho
character is
one and that by doing so you
transcend all of those nonsensical
that is some that is god that is deity
that is what i am not all of that type
of stuff
and so it's a simple change in the lens
to go from okay watch when you get
really good at this you can do it at the
speed
you can go from i am a person
lens to you can shift that to i am
formless impersonal eternal awareness
lens
and then you can shift from you went a
big shift into subtlety from that first
one
and then you can shift into the i am the
source of infinite
possibilities lens i am the infinite
creator lens
and if you can really navigate between
those three
really lenses really kind of smoothly
and you can navigate the nothingness
lens and the everythingness lens if you
can
kind of navigate these lenses you can
really find a
peaceful blissful way to just flow
effortlessly through life
which is what it is you are a flower
expressing itself or aromatically
on the planet growing towards the sun
effortlessly
and your mind is just toiling you around
wait you're playing out of tune in the
symphony
because you're attached to some sort of
layer of identity that formed thanks to
your ignorant parents and the ignorant
matrix that we built ourselves
for this exact process of getting us out
of the mazeless maze
the ex the lock-less escape room
so you said something about flowers and
i just want to tell you like i'll tell
you guys a story about
about how the buddha was going to give
like the best sermon in the world
like one of his last sermons like the
sermons of all sermons
it's almost exactly the ocean story i
talked about so he walked down to the
painted
the podium there's all thousands of
people trying to receive his blessing
right trying to learn the dharma of all
dharmas
and then the buddha he just took out
flowers he just goes like this
he just took out the flower he just held
it and there's only one person in the
entire stadium
that truly knew what he was talking
about and he just nodded the buddha and
the buddha narrated him
that was it that's exactly my experience
with osho i was like hey man
if you really understood what osha was
talking about you wouldn't be clapping
at this man you would be like this man
exactly the same as me there's
absolutely no distinction at all between
osho and me
and also sees no distinction at all
either boom
that's why ocean never that's why also
went into the space of like three or
four years of silence
he was saying like he was he was saying
like i've been speaking so much 15 years
i've been talking nonstop in 15 years
but i feel like i'm talking to a wall
because so many few people understand
the simplest truth
yeah i was like i understand what this
man was trying to do trying to say
just just by looking his eyes he's being
silent so like the buddha just holding
out a flower
this is the dominant of all damas that's
good enough now here's the
here's the flower
perfect i think that's a great great
place to end it
likewise i was just thinking the same
thing it's 11 11.
on my clock and it's 11 11 in taiwan
boom
perfect see even more boom
whoa
it's effortless the whole
two-hour convo so flow so
smooth effortless just like the
hydrological cycle
on the planet and thank you for
the ending of that beautiful this
is the dharma look
[Music]
all right boom that's episode number two
with frank yang costume
we love it we love the the i am loves
the
dialectic between the frank and atlas
costumes
it's really strong it's uh hopefully
helping
a lot of people that are watching and
that's the key is to be in service to
the other costumes that are seeking
that true nature that they already are
yeah it's consciousness wants to wake up
to itself that's the only projection of
the early trajectory of consciousness is
to wake up to itself
so you can do you do do whatever it
means possible you know
this moment he's doing it through the
franking in the atlas costume
but even without us consciousness would
still try to wake up to itself
regardless even during dark times
because darkness only comes in
accordance in uh
codependent will rise with lightness
right love and hate caught him in the
rice
yeah yep yep and that's the whole office
is consciousness recognizes itself and
he's doing it through
genocides as well as through unity love
it's all the
two sides of the same coin but if you
tell people this then they have no
concept of non-duality they're going to
think you're evil
but evil only arrives out of goodness so
you know you transcend all that duality
yes about duality now the moment you see
something is beautiful you recognize
this is opposite as well
you can't recognize ugly without beauty
and vice versa no
yeah all is that love
light white network theory at play
and that we color
up the half of that with that darkness
to
it and that's the monus plus duelist in
one symbol the taijitsu
the yin yang plus monism in one symbol
so
the dark light let's return to the dark
light right now
dark line
uh
[Music]
let me play a bell and then we'll end it
let's play a dharma belt perfect
let's play dharma bell yes
i like how we both as that was coming
through we both said
it was beautiful
this has psych though just give me one
man
that's good
[Music]
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so thanks everyone for tuning in
everybody
yeah we adore you infinitely thanks so
much for tuning in
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below write us out a
comment let us know
what you think about the episode where
you're at we'll see if frank and i can
potentially
come in and hit a tennis ball back to
help you out
and like the video if it brought you
value it helps the algorithm
also subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet share
the video with people that you know this
would positively
influence that's critical as well and
check out the links in the bio below
you can find the first episode we did
with frank
we'll have that link below also check
out the
frank's youtube channel has a lot of
awesome content that links in the bio
below check that out
also frank's instagram has a lot of
awesome content that links in the bio
this is gonna go for one hour bro so
check out all those links in the bio
below
infinite love and adoration frank
thank you what a stellar round two
thank you the eternal bra the eternal
bra
all right we'll stay in the studio much
love everyone i'm gonna end the
broadcast
peace